You
She's a scream of horror.
It's fine.
I'm going to get the carrot.
I'm not going to get the carrot.
Should we redo this level?
Yeah, you want to get the carrot?
I think it's past the portal.
We're going to try to get like the carrot.
All right, you're in front.
Don't kick me in the face.
OK, how do we get out of here without dropping?
I think, hold on, let me position myself.
I think I can kick you across.
Oh, shit, OK.
Just a moment.
Hold on, I'm almost there.
I'm so close.
OK, that's not going to work.
I need to flip.
It's fine.
I'm getting into position.
Yes, get into position.
Oh, damn it, that didn't work.
This is how I move around.
Did you want to do it again?
It's OK, we can try again.
All right, what if we just launch ourselves?
What if we just launch ourselves?
I'm going to.
What's happening?
Why are you planking?
I thought I was going to fall.
All right, what if I just got a scooch?
Nope, nope.
No, sorry.
I'm so sorry.
Oh, I killed her.
I killed her.
I'm so sorry.
I hate you too.
Oh.
I'm an acrobat.
As you say, anything you say.
Yandere, queen.
Oh, wait, hold on.
Let me just.
It works.
All right, I believe in you, Marcy.
No, Marcy.
It's fine, it's fine.
Damn it.
Next level.
Sure.
It's only going to get harder from here, girly pop.
It's OK.
Yeah.
All right, it's a little gap.
All right, I think.
Oh, don't kill yourself.
OK, OK.
Can you?
All right.
How do I kick again?
Yeah.
Damn it.
You got to jump over that.
Nice.
You got this.
Oh, so carefully.
Do you remember how to grab?
I left a button.
Yes.
You got it.
Oh, yes, queen.
Flip to victory.
Oh, you did it.
Nice job.
Oh, my god.
Why does it say we didn't get the carrot?
It said I got the carrot.
Oh, I just don't count.
Yeah.
Is it behind us?
Sorry.
Pardon me.
Excuse me.
It's not.
All right, it's fine.
Acrobatics, acrobatics, acrobatics.
Why am I holding on to you?
Because we need each other.
Yeah.
Imagine you could jump like this.
Let's see.
Mercy carry.
I don't think so.
No.
All right, we can also help each other over the gaps.
Hold on.
I'll be there shortly.
One moment.
If I flip.
There we go.
See, now we're a little bit longer,
so we can flip over the gap.
Oh.
Yeah, so you got to rotate.
Perfect.
We are speed.
I got you.
Don't worry.
We are speed.
We are.
Wait, where's the carrot?
Where's the carrot?
It's back there.
No, Mercy.
Is it level?
OK.
Mercy's like, I'm not even going to bother going
for the carrot.
What's that place?
I don't know.
Why don't you find out?
You got it?
Oh, hello.
Hold on.
I need you.
You need?
Oh, fuck.
She just took me.
I just got kidnapped.
Please do not throw me to my death, sister.
Let's go.
All right.
I need to hold on to me because I
want to be able to cross this gap.
How do I do this?
It's a great question.
Perfect.
All right.
Wow.
We are a wheel.
We are the first wheel invented.
Oh, no, stop.
We were not going to make that.
OK, we have to jump over.
Mercy, you got to go first.
You're in front.
I got to be first.
No, yeah, you got to go.
Oh, god.
You got this.
Yes.
Yes, queen.
All right.
I'll be there in a moment.
Yeah.
Let's go.
Nice.
We're such gods at this.
Wow.
Oh, shit.
I'm actually I'm surprised at how well we're doing.
Oh, oh, hold on.
Oh, don't die.
Oh, nice job.
Impressive.
All right.
Oh, oh, you got this.
Oh, nice, nice, straight leg.
Save.
Carrot.
You want to get it this time here?
I accidentally jumped backwards, so it's all used.
I'll try my best.
Oh, no, I had seltzer water and I need to burp.
I'm stuck.
I got you.
Oh, yeah, you can take it.
I'm sorry.
I took the carrot, not you.
It's OK.
I just got to get it out.
All right.
Yeah.
I'm going backwards.
Oh, what's happening?
Oh, OK, I'm fine.
We're good.
No, mercy, please.
Acquired.
Wait, you dropped the carrot.
No, I didn't.
Oh, never mind.
Oh, yeah, sometimes for this game, it's like,
Lilly, NC is really weird.
Sometimes you'll fly off the screen and then come back.
Oh, I'm being taken with.
Oh, no longer.
Ah!
Oh, I'm fine.
It's OK, I'm good.
With the carrots up there, I think.
I know.
It's fine.
Hwa.
Yeah.
Wait, where is the hole?
Where is the hole?
OK, it's OK.
Just a flesh wound.
Just a little flesh wound.
It's fine.
Why is your blood like that?
I don't know.
Oh, you just, it's your good.
This thing, I just got your little toesies.
It's got a little toesies.
I'm going to hold on to you.
What?
Oh, no!
You left me for dead!
I'm so sorry!
I killed her!
I killed my daddy!
I'm so sorry!
I'm horrible!
Give me!
Give me a kiss in here!
I'm so sorry!
Wait, now what?
I'm just stuck!
I'm impaled!
Wait, move?
Are you not dead?
Why are you here?
Why are you fucking dead?
Wait, press the X button.
Because it should have, it should have,
restocked it by now if you died.
All right, go back to the medial to restart this one.
Let's pretend this never happened.
Number seven?
Yeah, I think it was number seven.
The senpais are raging.
I'm so sorry, senpais.
They're okay.
Okay, I scared myself.
All right, you got this, Mercy.
You can jump across, I believe in you.
Oh, yeah, the tree gets in the way a little bit.
You might have to lean forward.
You might have to like tilt like this and then jump.
Oh, uh, I'm in a pickle.
Never mind.
Avenge me!
It's fine, I'm just gonna swing.
No, Mercy, why?
Why?
You're not gonna go!
I wasn't about to let you die, Comrade.
Thank you.
All right, okay, so it's fine, I'm just gonna...
Just gonna rock with it.
Pro strats.
Nice.
I almost got it, she's making momentum.
It doesn't matter, I'm probably gonna die on this, it's fine.
Let me just edge a little closer.
Oh my god, I am a master.
Hold on, I'm gonna throw this carrot down to you.
Okay.
Where'd I fucking go?
Oh, we gotta go back.
Okay.
You can grab it, if you can grab it.
I grabbed you!
I can't do this!
I'm trying to push it towards you.
Okay, I got it.
No, I grabbed the ground.
Okay, now I got it.
Oh gosh, my cat just jumped on my desk, hold on.
Boomie, please.
Oh gosh, I couldn't see.
All right, lead the way.
Okay.
She's doing sit-ups.
Don't...
She'll be the backup for you.
Maybe just a little bit.
It's okay, you got this.
You don't got this, it's fine, it's fine.
I can't even kill myself properly.
Oh, there we go.
All you.
Oh shit.
I'm clapping.
It's like it's hurting you every flip.
All right, it's fine.
Oh wait, I'll backup.
Nice form, amazing.
I think I just started lightning outside my window.
Holy crap, that was bright.
Yes!
We didn't get the carrot.
But we got each other.
It wasn't about the destination, it was the journey.
What the fuck is this?
Oh, it's a little bouncy thing.
Can we bounce backwards?
You might have to bounce backwards on top of each other.
Quick.
That's hard.
I don't know if we can...
Can I like, grab onto your legies?
Maybe.
And then we have like, you know...
Extra jump, go for it.
I'm being smacked in the face by this thing.
Oh, okay, well...
Oh, I need your butt.
I'm trying so hard.
Oh wait, I got you.
Oh, hello.
This is quite romantic, to be honest.
I think we're both too heavy for this thing.
All right.
Man, that was romantic.
That was, we just held each other and bounced around.
We could have kissed.
We really wanted.
We could.
Kissed.
What did I need to do?
This bitch keeps on killing me.
Wait, I didn't tweet with that.
I was live.
Did you tweet with that you were live?
No, I didn't.
Okay, let's tweet that we're live.
There's thunder and lightning outside my house right now.
Are you gonna be okay?
I hope so.
Okay, I can tweet that right now.
Oops, been live for like 30 minutes already.
That's usually how it works for me.
I casually foregoer.
Live and hysterically laughing.
I keep accidentally killing Mercy.
Whoops.
Get in here.
Hold on.
I'm just gonna quote, retweet yours.
Alrighty.
There we go.
Where's my live button?
Perfect.
She be a murderer.
Hello, is there a nothing to see here?
Sometimes my BDSM play gets a little bit too rough.
Yeah, but you know, Mercy's not, you know,
unfamiliar with a little pain.
You got this, Mercy.
I'll back up.
You got this.
I believe in you.
I believe in you so hard.
Okay, it's fine.
Let me just...
Romeo and Juliet impaled through my ass.
I got impaled with this bike up my IF.
Alright, we're doing good so far.
Yeah.
Oh, well, I'm fine.
You're good.
I wonder if you could throw the carrot across.
Oh my God.
I'm so scared.
She's going to launch herself into the spikes.
Hi.
Mercy is durable indeed.
Oh my gosh.
She is straddling that carrot.
Try to grab the carrot.
I'll die with you, my queen.
When the gamer and the non-gamer play games.
Please.
Oh God.
I'm not a gamer.
What do you mean?
Ask the harem.
That's the one who played.
Alright.
It's my time to shine.
I will try my best.
Yes.
When I try my best, I mean go backwards.
I mean...
Never mind.
It's fine.
I was going to see if I could jump back over,
but it didn't really work out.
Well...
Join me in the embrace of death.
Together our bodies and blood intertwined.
69, baby.
Wee.
You're just doing flips in the air on my screen
for no reason.
Because you're not touching me.
Oh, I got you.
I got you.
Don't move.
I will grab you.
Hold on.
Let me just figure this out.
I saw I had it.
I got you.
Let go.
I am letting go.
Oh.
Perfect.
Okay.
I'll never let go.
What?
I'm trying to avoid the thingy.
If I need to.
All right.
Why did you get bit down?
I don't even...
I don't even know what happened there.
I think we should f the carrot on this one.
Wee.
If I randomly lose power,
it's because the raging thunderstorm
outside my house randomly.
Oh, I'll join you.
My legs spread.
Retty to accept death
in its purest form.
Like how did I badly mess up?
Fuck these trees.
You got it.
All right.
Careful.
Perfect.
Okay, we got it.
All right.
Fuck that carrot.
Good.
Oh, I almost kicked you off.
Oh my God.
We're fine.
Okay.
We have one issue.
We do have an issue.
It's okay.
I'm going to grab you.
I got you.
Let go.
You got me?
Yeah.
I tried.
In the end, it didn't even matter.
Oh my God.
Mercy.
Oh, God.
Actually do that.
Perfect.
I'm keeping you with me.
Maybe I shouldn't have kept you with me.
I like how we're only on like the first area.
Yeah.
Okay.
Will we ever pass the gap of spikes?
No, but we will 69 while we die.
Like how bad are we at this game?
I'm pretty fucking bad.
I won't admit.
I don't even know how you can be good at this game though.
Nice.
Impressive.
Okay.
Oh, never mind.
I tried.
That was so close.
Oh, you want to hold on?
Yeah.
Well, I think we're stuck.
I am.
Let go.
Okay.
Perfect.
Are you okay?
Are you fucking dead?
I'm dead.
Take my dead body with you.
Okay.
Wait, where were we supposed to go after that?
No, once one of us dies, we can't finish the level.
Oh.
So the thing disappears.
What the fuck is happening?
I was holding on.
Okay.
Perfect.
We're good.
I let go.
Nice.
All right.
Grab my ass.
Are you ready?
I grabbed your ass.
Yeah.
Are you ready?
Okay.
That was supposed to have the opposite effect.
I was hoping it would propel us forward, but it didn't.
I just saw a red flash of lightning outside my window.
That was pretty cool.
Red?
Yep.
Okay, I'm good.
Those back shots, I suppose.
I was going to grab you.
Well, now I have to grab you.
Hold on.
Please.
Sorry, my fat ass killed you.
I know I got dragon lightning outside of my house right now.
Dragon deez ball.
Sorry.
Anyways.
Oh, nice kick.
Nice kick.
If only we could get over this fucking line.
What was that?
Wait, I'm going to hold on and then you can kick off.
Ready?
Go.
Go as hard as you can.
Why do we go backwards when this happens?
Maybe if we aim the other way.
Can we blast off?
All right.
Well, I'm just going to take you with me.
I'll let go.
Oh.
Hold on just a moment.
What if I...
Well, goodbye, carrot.
Do a cheeky...
Well, bye, me.
Yeah, there's a physics glitch where if you hold on to each other's feet, you can like
propel yourself across the game.
So I was trying to do that.
Will we ever get past this level?
I don't know.
We're going to try.
But...
I believe in us.
We'll do it.
Oh, sorry.
I fucked up your jump.
Let me back up.
Don't worry.
Whoa.
Impressive landing.
Impressive death even more so.
Wait, it showed that you died for me.
It didn't show that you died for me.
I think people on my side can see that you're just glitching profusely.
Oh, what the hell?
Wait, you're still alive?
Yeah.
Oh.
Nice.
Oh my God, Mercy.
You're so goaded.
Let's go.
Baby Chibi, you should take the carrot.
You want me to take the carrot?
All right.
Carrot acquired.
Mercy glitched the system.
Are you in front of me or behind me?
I'm in front of you.
Okay, I just want to make sure.
Because again, sometimes the game will reflect something else.
Oh, Mercy.
It's okay.
Oh my God, I got a carrot.
Okay.
All you got to do is make it across.
Immediately dies.
It's fine.
We got this.
Yeah.
It's fine.
You're good.
All according to plan.
69 each time.
Every time in death, we just die in another sex position.
Very, very on character for us.
All right.
Let's go.
You got it.
Nice.
Amazing landing.
Can you back up?
I don't want to actually kick you and then make you fly across to your death.
All right.
You got to angle this.
Oh my fucking God.
This game is called super buddy man.
Hello.
I'm playing with Mercy.
Mercy, you can just die.
I died, Mercy.
I have to like literally wiggle my way down.
I know sometimes it gets increasingly hard to kill yourself in this game.
All right.
Oh my God.
Oh, okay.
Let me go back for you.
Hold on.
It's okay.
Goodbye.
No, I was coming back.
I literally could have grabbed her.
Size and pale self on spikes.
I'm sorry.
I truly am.
So sorry.
We're all in this together.
Watching you slowly sit up to grab the carrot is really funny.
Amazing execution.
Oh, no.
Oh.
What?
I love this game.
It's just, you just have a bunch of laughs.
It's just the funniest thing ever.
It's like so gentle and then immediately hold on.
Can you back up?
Okay.
I'm good.
Oh.
Layed it on my face.
Oh, it's fine.
Amazing recovery.
Yes.
Yeah.
You get the carrot.
You want me to get the carrot?
I'll try.
And when I say I'll try, I mean I'll almost.
Okay.
All right.
Carrot acquired.
You're still your hateful one.
Yes.
You recovered.
What the heck?
Let's fucking go.
I got the carrot.
I love you.
Glitch that.
I don't know.
Sometimes the game glitches.
It looks like you die, but you don't.
All right.
All we got to do, Mercy, is make it across.
Oh, Mercy.
Mercy.
Mercy, I need your help.
Mercy, I need you to grab me.
Mercy.
Mercy, please.
I'm trying my best.
Just a little hard to get over this.
I'm slowly sliding down.
I'm slowly sliding to my death.
Please.
Mercy, please.
Give me a second.
I got you.
Oh, thank God.
I thought I was a goner.
All right.
I'll give you some space.
Go on.
Give me a second.
Watch out for the red button.
Impressive.
Amazing.
She is the moment.
See what I mean by like that area is hard.
Yep.
All right.
See if you can jump over the button.
The thing is just on the other side.
You might want to lean the other way.
I'm going to lean the other way.
Not that way.
Oh, my God.
If I could just...
Okay.
All right.
Go to the portal.
Amazing.
All right.
Don't die.
God, I laughed so hard.
I nearly peached my shell.
I'm like, don't die.
And I just immediately fucking die.
All right.
I ruined that.
It's all right.
Okay.
Hold on.
I try.
Let me just kill myself.
Oh, hello.
Oh, perfect.
That worked.
Oh, I'm going the wrong way.
All right.
I fucked that carrot.
And me too, apparently.
I hate that.
This is going to become a rage game if you don't get past this level.
You're standing on my body.
Can I stand on your body?
What the hell?
Being a rabbit in the hoppy hills.
Playing games.
And shit.
Doing...
Yeah.
Shit.
Nice.
All right.
We're getting somewhere.
Oh, my God.
This might be it, guys.
This might be...
Oh, hello.
All right.
Actually, that might be helpful.
Perfect.
Oh, no.
Oh, nice job.
Wait, shit.
Okay.
Fuck the carrot.
We launched into orbit.
All right.
Sorry.
I'm so sorry.
Oh.
Oh, what the hell?
Oh, at least there's not spikes here.
But there's spikes over there.
Am I dead?
I think you are.
How did you die?
I don't know.
Weird.
You, like, died off screen.
I died off screen.
I was like, where did I go?
Maybe you hit the spike and we didn't see.
I don't know.
Oh.
His face flooded into my ass.
It's okay.
Her ass smells nice.
I did take a shower today.
Amazing precision.
All right.
It's okay.
It's not okay.
Almost first try.
We almost did it.
This is definitely an easier one.
I feel like we can do, though.
I think I can get the carrot.
Yeah.
Easy peasy.
Carrot acquired.
If I could, if I could just, can I, can I please just,
if I could, if I could just, please.
Oh, there we go.
All right, Mercy.
I'm just going to go to the portal.
If I can get over this thing.
I'm trying my best.
I'm sorry.
I know it's hard.
I was also like struggling.
So I don't blame you at all.
It's funny.
You're doing the stuff in like slow motion on my screen.
Okay.
There's something over here that should kill us.
It's a gap.
Oh my God.
You got it.
I was so careful.
I'm like, you got the, why is every, I'm never speaking.
I'm always just like, oh, we got this.
And then we just immediately die.
All right.
Oh, how did I get down here?
We got each other.
Just the two of us.
All right.
You probably can grab that carrot.
Can I grab a carrot?
I'm just going to be doing fucking flips on this thing.
Why am I just in the air?
What is happening?
Help, grab me.
I got you.
Okay.
Oh wait, we actually should be able just to go over like this.
Yeah.
All right.
We should have done that.
Oh, let go.
Nice.
All right.
I got it.
I need to just scoop forward.
Nice.
I see the perfect.
All right.
So there's a little gap and you just got to jump across it.
I believe in you.
Maybe you should grab the carrot.
You want me to grab the carrot?
I'll grab the carrot.
Wait, maybe we should hold on to each other.
I don't, I think we have to jump this.
I don't think, if we try to flip, I think we'll just kill ourselves.
Oh, okay.
Unless you want, we can try.
What if we both grab the carrot?
If I could just, if I could please.
It's okay.
You can jump.
I won't even let me get it.
Okay.
Here, I'll grab it.
You may grab it.
I got it.
I shouldn't have grabbed the carrot.
I shouldn't have grabbed it.
Give me a second.
I want to see if there's like a possibility of us,
of me shooting.
Shooting your shot.
Yeah.
Across the thing.
Go for it.
No.
You just have to like, you have to angle like this.
So I'll show you.
You just got to, you just got to be like this.
You got to lean forward.
You got to balance, but go forward and then jump like that across.
Like that.
Here, let me just grab you.
Oh.
I let go.
All right.
Or I could kick you across that gap.
Give me a second.
There you go.
Well, welcome back.
Welcome back.
Give me a second.
I'll give you a second.
Or maybe more than one second.
Yeah.
I almost got it.
I got the carrot.
Let's make it over now.
Oh.
Okay.
It's fine.
Grappy.
You might be able to grab me.
Never mind.
It's so ogre.
Kick me in the face.
I can kick you in the face.
No.
Give me a second.
Give me a push me forward a little.
That was just dead silence as I just flew away to my death.
Let's go.
What is that?
That's the physics glitch.
Oh, hi kitty.
You need to get out of the way kitty.
I can't see kitty.
Oh my gosh.
I can't see myself.
Did I fucking die?
Oh, no.
I can't see myself either.
Oh, there I am.
Nice.
Let's go.
I don't know what happened.
I don't know how that happens.
That's all up to you now.
Take your time.
It's so ogre for me.
Take your time, Mercy.
Think it through.
Yep.
Scooch a little bit closer.
And then when you're at a nice 45 degree angle,
you're going to want to tip in the forward direction.
So lean forward.
Go for it.
Yeah.
When you're at that like teetering point,
you're about to be on your hands and knees.
Give me it.
Take your time.
It's all right.
Just take your time.
Think, be careful.
Think it through.
You're fine.
You're good.
You got this.
You're amazing, Mercy.
So amazing.
Just lean forward.
Just a tad.
Jump.
Yeah.
Mercy, let's go.
My girl.
That's my genome right there, everybody.
All right.
What's going on over here?
It's okay.
I just got a little bit of my toesies.
I'm good.
Be careful.
Nice.
I got you.
Come back.
Don't worry.
I got you.
Yeah.
This is like a great team building exercise game.
We should grab each other's legs or something.
That's a good idea.
There you go.
It's okay.
We're getting somewhere.
This is working out perfectly.
What if I lean up?
Oh.
This is impressive.
I have amazing upper body strength.
Wait, see if you can flip over on my body.
Let go of me.
Oh, no, that didn't work.
No, that didn't work.
Oh, wait, wait, wait.
Actually, you might be able to use your legs to propel yourself up.
Yeah.
Use me like a springboard.
I'll hang out just like this.
You just kick me in the ass.
I'll try to grab your leggings.
Nice.
Oh, almost got it.
Sorry.
I'm trying to angle myself better.
Nice.
All right.
I'll figure this out.
How do we get you?
I am the bunny master.
Mercy, where'd you go?
I definitely got up here.
Where'd she go?
Down.
To my town.
We're going down, down in an early area.
Yeah, to my death.
I'm so strong.
Um.
Whoops.
I'm fine.
Just my hands.
Oh, sorry.
My cat's food is going off.
Oh, you're ready?
Me?
I'm like a bunny.
I flipped through.
Okay.
Let me just.
Yep.
Okay.
All right.
Yeah.
You want to lean a little bit more forward.
Perfect.
Nice.
Oh, yes.
Incredible.
All right.
Let me let's do what we did before.
Oh, you don't even need me.
We did it.
Oh my God.
We're pros.
Oh.
I'm so sorry.
What happened?
I accidentally, when I tried to jump over the gap,
I kicked you back at the same time.
Hold on.
Let me go.
Your body is facing through the walls.
Oh, is it?
On your end, I'm on just on top.
Let me see if I can fix it by grabbing you.
Okay.
Hello.
I was such a pro for a second.
Oh, okay.
Oh, you can keep rolling like this.
Go forward.
Yeah.
Nice.
Wow.
We are so good at this.
Wait.
Oh, the carrots right there.
Is it a trap?
No, it's not.
We're good.
All right.
I'll grab the carrot.
If I could just.
The carrot.
The trap up here.
I got it.
Oh, nice.
All right.
I'll let you go first.
You got this.
Oh, definitely.
Oh.
Yep.
Oh, God.
So nervous.
I'm so scared you're going to roll into the button.
Hold on.
Let me get back up there so you can see better.
Oh, nice job.
Nice job.
Okay.
No.
Let me let me join you.
All right.
Let me just.
You have to jump over because we're going to fuck each other for over there.
Nice recovery.
Oh, God.
I love watching mercy work.
Work out what she's going to do next.
Nice.
Oh, my gosh, mercy.
You're incredible.
Okay.
Now I just can't fuck this up.
I'm good.
It's okay.
I stabbed my footsie a little bit, but it's fine.
Oh, all right.
What?
I grabbed it.
Oh, okay.
Oh, at least on my end I did.
But if it if it shows up for you, you can grab it.
You're you're in perpetual.
I already got in.
So the game's just glitching.
Oh, mercy.
Please.
I'm sorry.
You did it.
Yay.
Wait, I did it.
On my side.
You did.
Yeah.
It still says unlocked.
Really?
Oh, we need to get more.
We needed to get more coins.
Okay.
So let's go back to the menu and then we need one more coin.
So we should probably go get a carrot for one of them.
Number one looks like the easiest one.
Did we already grab that carrot?
No, wait.
Did we not?
Yeah.
Hold on.
Oh, we can do the time thing really fast.
Yeah.
Oh, we weren't.
We were already too slow.
All right.
Yeah.
Let's try that again.
Try that again.
The time one should be easier.
Go.
Fucking trees.
Never mind.
We start.
Go.
Fuck.
Damn it.
I was too slow.
Is six minutes good enough?
No, we gotta see how there's like a ghost.
You have to do it in five seconds.
What?
Yep.
Go.
Oh, I fucked up.
So you can see the little ghost bunny.
It's like it's a ghost race from Mario.
Can I please get up?
I've never done a ghost race for Mario before.
Mario Kart?
I'm so sorry.
I'm so slow.
No, no, no.
It's also it's like whoever's behind like the second person.
It's hard to get the momentum because you're already at a disadvantage.
Oh my gosh.
It's older.
Killing myself.
Farewell.
Well, just keep going.
Oh, it's a cat.
I never noticed that before.
Okay.
Maybe we should do a carrot one.
Yeah.
We didn't do four carrot.
Let's try that one.
Where's the carrot?
Was the carrot behind us or in front of us?
I never get.
Hold on.
No.
It was in front of us.
Oh yeah.
There's like, yeah, there's one that.
That was a trap.
I could just, if I could, perfect.
Butt to butt.
I got you.
Don't worry about it.
We got it.
Yeah.
Where's a carrot for this one?
Oh, it's down there.
Oh, that's an easy one to grab.
Yeah.
Let me try to grab it.
Yeah, you got that.
I'm going to go in the portal.
All you girly pop.
Nice use of feet.
Mercy's good with her feet, everybody.
Not so much your hands.
I think you're grabbing the floor.
Nice.
You got it.
Yeah.
Good job.
We did it.
Can I go menu now?
Yes.
Then you should be able to do that.
You should be able to go the next level.
Where is it?
That's a great question.
Go.
Why isn't it?
We have 15.
Why isn't it automatically unlocking it?
Do we have to do it again?
Do you want to try to do 10 again and hopefully it'll prompt it?
Maybe.
Yeah, let's try it.
I'm going to cry.
We don't have to.
It said 15 on the lock.
Why isn't it letting me move?
Oh, there you go.
Kick you across.
Yes.
How does somebody do this in a short amount of time?
Very smartly.
I'll back up.
Give you some space, queen.
Yeah.
Amazing.
Flawless.
Yes.
Shit.
You know, sometimes you just get stuck in places like me getting stuck here right now.
Oh, grab my feet.
If you don't need the carrot, we already grabbed it before.
Grab my toesies.
Oh, god damn it.
I'm trying to grab your feet, queen.
Or grab any part of me.
You might be able to jump and grab.
Oh, shit.
Yeah.
I can't move.
Okay.
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, god.
I'm going back.
I'm going to wait my turn.
I'll be taking this and saving it for later.
Thank you very much.
Perfect.
Just amazing.
I'm stuck.
Step pro, I'm stuck.
Oh, well.
Rolling, rolling, rolling, rolling.
What?
Pro, pro.
Don't ever think it, mercy.
You got this.
Nice.
All right.
Time to get the fuck up here again.
I'm back up.
Nice.
Got it.
Me, not so much.
I made room for you.
Oh.
Help.
I'm just going to sit here and watch and creep.
Oh, god.
Nice.
Yep.
Nice scoot.
Amazing.
You did it.
Nice job.
Let me not fall to my death.
Please.
There we go.
Yeah.
Next level.
Oh, we're in snowy place now.
Okay.
So there's ice.
Wee.
Oh.
This is going to be a hard one.
Wait, I'm fine.
All right.
Let me just.
Damn it.
Carrots going to be hard to get.
I'm so sorry.
Mercy, just go in here.
Yeah.
Kick off.
Nice.
Amazing.
All right.
Ready?
Lock in.
She's just on her back.
Watch out for the spikes right there.
Nice job.
All right.
You're good.
You're somehow still alive.
I'm impressed.
Let me grab you.
Let me see if I can grab.
I can do it.
Never mind.
Oh, sweet.
Okay.
Perfect.
Yeah.
Oh gosh.
Teamwork makes the dream work.
Where's the carrot up here?
Is it up there?
I don't know.
I'll lean back and see and you can scope it out.
Oh, it's up there.
How the fuck?
I was going to say.
Yeah.
Oh, okay.
Yeah, yeah.
Yeah.
How does she die?
Oh, I died.
I didn't even.
This game sucks.
All right.
Nice.
Incredible oh recovery I got you take my hand
hold it on all right is this the strat it's not the strat
what a way to go what a way to go oh my gosh oh okay you did it what are you
talking about I might die though perfect um okay oh no yeah us dying
together is so romantic you were right here I'm so romantic this might be the
one that breaks us boys especially we have to make that jump to over all those
spikes somehow oh I got too greedy I got too greedy there we go
I would die was she be too good we're good I usually back up in it like I lean
forward and then I push off yeah yeah and that's how I do that kissing your
feetsies what if I kick you over can I do that hold on can you uh sorry I have to moonwalk
real quick let me just don't mean to lean back a little I'll figure this out
are you glitched to the map for me and fell through the floor I just died died how did
that happen oh sorry let me back up how are there flowers growing like this this reminds
me of like Mario world hey you got it yeah amazing all right let me not fuck it up now
all right so be careful so you're gonna want to really push off and kick off because of the
little um the jump you glitched for me and you like we're already dead at the top of the
thing so I was so confused okay I just spammed it oh I'm gonna do I'm gonna do some
scouting okay and scout scout for us all right so we got a snowball oh I bet that's
where the portal supposed to be yeah where that snowball fell off all right
huh I was like kicking my leggies
amazing oh you got this mercy amazing oh you almost made that you really got it you
got a kick off like when it while you're on the ice yeah let me just take a seat
fuck just happened oh hello come here often
amazing form oh nice recovery I mean let's go hold on to me oh no holding hands until
the very end on the hands we can't let go I can't out it's funny we just like flip
oh I look like I'm taking a poop help see you're just stuck there and then you can't
die there we go oh romantic damn we'd be dying in the most insane poses can I super
funny man that's a great that's a great question to be honest nice but wait did you die you're
just floating in the air for me why are my legs like that all right cool oh just spam
it you'll go across or not never mind I was just clicking act super fast hold snow about
all right I'm gonna wait till you cross and then I'll jump down nice oh impressive recovery
all right let me just all right so I'm gonna slide down let it work out I like hit a bump
what was that gonna see if I can jump up there all right it's possible it definitely is
I bet if you like grab onto the side
never mind guys I don't know if we're gonna cross this one this might be the one that
kills us I'm just humping mercy at this point nothing new there
oh what the hell I thought you died
uh I'll come grab you don't move don't move
69 even in death why am I like this
oh nice all right I'm gonna get some I'm gonna go backwards and then I'll launch myself across
oh see that's effective
uh I got you so I may need some help I got you thank you how do we get across like this though
uh I'm just like a bad idea
oh wait do that again let me just nice oh my gosh amazing
all right I'll let you let's I don't know how we're gonna do this you're gonna try to jump up
there again yep all right I'm gonna try I believe in you
I died like a fucking family guy character
I literally I would have made it my head
we could have had our own record
oh
mercy went super sonic she did
oh fuck
huh
it's fine oh oh god oh god
nice I think when my catch just took a poop in the litter box right next to me I'm dying
it smells so bad
you got it nice okay okay I just need to not fuck this up
can I jump up there sounds like so
oh we did it okay all right so there's a yeah knock that and I think that'll roll into the
spikes and cover it for us don't go just yet never mind it does yay okay cool
yeah we guys we did it you doubted us our own harem and some pies doubted us I couldn't
believe you guys I can't believe that harem would say such a thing to us
how are you supposed to do this oh maybe we can oh that worked out yeah
all right let's go oh we're fine
oh mercy I think I'll let go of me
you don't want to let go I don't want to ever let go
oh yeah kick off really fast nice
take it
I feel like there's a death over here
oh oh I made it I'll be there momentarily
in a in a second in just a small second I'll make it over there we go
what are you doing I'm trying to make a bridge for you yeah okay let's see if this works and
I'll grab you oh I didn't grab you it's okay I got myself oh okay
okay
mercy sacrificed herself so that I could live mercy is
let's go
oh
you almost got this
see if you can't grab the ice can you can't grab the ice
what if you kick off
I don't know if you could kick off and let go I don't know if that'll work
oh
you almost got it mercy I believe in you so hard
let's go mercy let's go that's it it's over oh yeah uh you're so close I almost did it though
that was impressive actually
yelling like r2d2 over here
wait I did the same thing
where am I where am I where am I
I can't find you I can't see I don't know I don't see because I'm still swimming back here
I'm so sorry did we fuck her did I fuck that it went so far
I'm still alive you're still alive I'm just I can't see myself so I can't bring myself over
never mind I think you died but the timer's still going
maybe it's letting me are you gonna come across my body and just like
hoping I don't come across your body
where did I go did I fly off the map oh I went through
what let's go we're killing this level this is like easier than the
fucking woodsy place let's see if I can get across
fuck oh never mind oh never mind
all right well I know where the carrot is
yoooo
careful
amazing form grab the ice grab it why didn't
don't ask me why I didn't do that I'm an idiot I forgot where the grab button was
all right make a my way downtown walking fast I'm still iced
okay I'm gonna grab this carrot MLG MLG MLG bunny moves
okay
why is grabbing this damn carrot so hard I got it
I can't I don't want to just jump over I'm trying to
I'm sorry but you're your yandere your wife is kind of stupid oh okay do I just fall
oh wait what oh well that sign was a lie that sign was a fucking lie what the fuck the hell
oh
wait let me back up like how he pulls his back
it's okay I'll figure this out if I can
oh
this is hard
never mind uh well it's gonna take me a moment to kill myself
please bear with me that's what I said earlier oh my god
right where I'm supposed to be
you
but well I never might fuck
oh fuck
I apologize for my where me and Mercy are both locked in
I'm bad at video games I'm so sorry it's fine I just died just me I just died it's good
oh you died yeah I died up top give me a second as I figure out how to jump over this
this is stupid yeah I want it's hard to get over that
fuck oh that's hard yeah you know what that one that area is hard oh this maybe this is the one
that breaks us
oh there we go
oh
no Mercy don't kill me I was leaning backwards you lean forwards
I just have her body
you're doing handstands on her body
can I use your body
you're doing indecent things to it I'm trying to use your bodies
I'm doing indecent things to it
hello
I'm already dead
okay please let me just have her
weekend at bunny's instead of Bernie's
I can't breathe this is so fucking funny
oh fuck what if I
oh oh nice okay perfect let's see if we both can go on top
yeah you got a yep nice
I don't know how to get over this uh
that's a great question
do you want me to go first oh you got it I got it
the all switcheroo
carrot I got it
all right so then we both have to go down this tube okay
okay are you holding on to me no are you holding on to the carrot
somehow the carrot's holding on to me okay that's weird let me let go of the carrot and
grab it again all right perfect now I can move all right let me not die
all right you've trained for this mercy
your entire life has led to this one moment
I can't even kill myself
I'll scout ahead I'll scout it oh okay we got that we got those
oh nice okay so the thing must be right here cool all right how do I
fuck
how do I kill myself all right what if we just
there we go
I got too nervous it was the thing
I was drinking my drink then I realized I was making it with mercy the entire time
what do you mean out of me
the most electable ambrosia it doesn't matter I'm dead
you're dead I died
this is the one we will defeat this this is this is the last thing we do
I'm saying fuck the carrot
oh mercy's getting the carrot I'll try to get over this fucking shit oh I did it
oh no oh my god I'm trying to stop moving
I can't fucking see now it'll hold on I made it
how are you alive I made it I made it I made it so you can just go for the carrot
nice
mercy's very good at writing carrots I do have to I do have to say
oh
she's writing like a broomstick
no no she's very good at writing carrots this ritual looks very weird all right let me just
you can do it
yeah yes that's fine
you got it all right
what if I drop the carrot down there and I don't just like slide down with it
if I can grab the fucking carrot bro
I'm still having trouble trying to get over the spike it's hard I can barely get over it
okay grab it
I think you have to go with it
how do you jump over it
all right well that's gonna walk you
let's see if I can do this with the carrot this is gonna be hard it's gonna take precision
all right yeah all right
all right
I look like I'm eating the carrot while I'm sitting here
fuck
sorry about this there's no to apologize I'm having like the five laugh this hard it's such a long
time are you enjoying your carrot I am I'm just sitting on the ledge just enjoying my carrot
son of a bitch and
that
yes you can you have made it over before
oh
all right what if I just
never mind
I'm so sorry
all right so you gotta like lean forward like this like that and then flip over it
like I gotta like lean like that and then jump that was pretty good
if I didn't fucking die but he's still a good job though
luckily I'm humping the snowman
mercy's never ending war with spikes is fascinating
I fucking hate spikes why don't you do you want to go try going in the up top then
I'm still gonna have to deal with the spine yeah but you were able to make those ones a
little bit easier oh actually yeah in general yeah you're right
fabulous
amazing like I just stiff legged it over that
nice all right
trying to grab the carrot it's very hard oh wait nice okay let's go
I can't believe we go are we gonna get the carrot on this one
help hold on let me
this is gonna be hard to get up oh you got it nice
do you want me to try doing it with the carrot
carrot acquired
why'd you just tip back like that I guess I'm scared you got this mercy easy claps
your gamer
it's your time to shine
yep
hmm it's okay mercy that's okay you did so good you're doing a great job
do you want to do you want to end it here and just talk to talk to chat
okay all right we're gonna do it we're gonna do it guys
every time this is what it's like when I play Elden Ring and I I try to kill a boss over and
over again and then when you finally make it it feels so good
well
yeah
well oh incredible
yep then grab yep
she's getting the strats boys
okay just gonna
slowly slides down onto the spike
you make it over that gap perfect all right let me see
let me slide on down it's actually good if one of us is down here because then it makes the
level a little bit bigger
nice
she's incredible ladies and gentlemen that dismount
unheard of and now watch me kill myself on these spikes
actually I'm gonna wait till I throw down the carrot
I'm gonna grab the carrot yep if I can grab the carrot give me the fucking carrot
it's very hard to grab the carrot for some reason on this one give me the fucking carrot
nice yeah you can just eat that to me
yeah whippy
whee
hey come here often
yeah where I die often
I just haven't been gamer enough my gamer skills can't do this
see if I can probably afford
yeah oh you want me to go before you yeah well you could have followed me okay
all right what if I just nope did you fucking die yes I fucking died
see it it's not just you mercy I have trouble with it too you're good
I'm so proud to know that you also have trouble yeah it's hard this game is difficult it's
supposed to be what see you made it she made the jump guys I made the jump but except I'm dead
wait menu sorry
I made the jump where when you died of course that's the time I die all right let's uh
yeah I don't even care
never mind
sorry you're good
doing push-ups I'm trying to figure out how to
it's that same position yeah it's hard to angle it
yeah lean forward yep son of a bitch you you made it you made it okay now I just don't have to
fuck it up all right all right
I'm dead
the spikes just got my head the curse has passed on to another
one problem oh all right
nice all right oh my I almost spiked my controller right there okay well I'm joining you
oh damn it's not going to my wife we turn on the light can't see
got it we will pass this level guys don't you worry
oh this little tickle tickle your rear oh yeah
yeah
oh yeah okay fine
yeah all right we got this I'm pretty I'm pretty confident
all right let me
ready to grab a carrot yeah let me just
uh my little grabby pause sorry I'm gonna balance on it for a second and apparently
oh this is hard to get the angle right with the carrot
oh all right
all right all right I'm gonna wait for you I'm gonna eat my carrot while I wait
delicious carrot
no
oh my god oh my god
oh my god folks folks we did it what the fuck I can't get over this thing
get the fuck out of the way snowball are you serious this is a snowball cucking us right now
what is this are you seeing this shit
ain't no way this fucking thing's all right all right okay all right we're good we're good
I was gonna say I was gonna oh mercy
oh my god yes
oh my god yes we did it
do not kick me go first
oh that was great oh I'm proud of us
oh this is see now I feel so satisfied
but you did that with the carrot too look at us oh uh uh uh oh
get in there get in there yeah
oh uh oh okay oh this is gonna be difficult oh fuck all right uh
this might be hard wait if we hold each other you might be fine
uh yep perfect all right now I can
oh
I'm coming for you babe oh how did that happen what the fuck
how did that even happen it glitched on my screen did I kick you or something
yes oh my screen you weren't near me when I did that I'm so sorry
hold on you should be able to grab me
legs yes yes
oh my god gorgeous let's knock that down
amazing what where is that going oh oh where's the carrot
of them I think I have to let you go now oh is the carrot up here
careful about those spikes over there oh oh I'm not even I'm not even gonna bother with that
no thanks I'm good nope
can I oh I thought I was gonna fly off
look at us look at us we're still kicking we're still going oh wait hold on
all right all right okay okay wait this one we have to hold on to it okay
okay you ready no we have to hold on to it like we have to not on to me I'm
on to the block oh okay this is arcing out oh that was fine nice
all right nifty um I don't know where we go next though I don't know if we go up or down
maybe we have to jump up
nice jump uh oh god yes oh no
well I think that was a ride
I think I knocked our ride away hold on to my legs let's go
okay so we have to be on the ice block so that um oh okay well we know now it goes automatically
what is this game it's called super buddy man you can play it with four people scrawny I think
okay go roll roll roll roll roll roll for your life go we got it we're good
yes nice nice that's fine
yes all right yeah
all right so just land on that platform
like like right here oh okay I'm gonna wait for you oh oh no oh no all right you gotta catch up to
you
what the hell you survived I don't know how I survived I'm gonna scout ahead I'm gonna scout
okay actually I think it's right here where the portal is yeah it must be it it's on Mercy's
bunny ears it almost as far as yours were my bunny ears are right here mother
all right let's flip on to this nice kneeling holding hands fabulous all right next one
where's he hold on to me
fabulous okay I'll let you go first amazing all right oh hold on
I got it all right so we just both both gotta
I stopped all right let me flip over and grab your feet
and then ready you're gonna hold on yep hold on oh we're holding on
oh my god we made it we did it
that was so fun
oh my god hey strani you want to see something funny no no no don't you do
I didn't even have to kick her off she did her she did the job herself
she panicked okay I thought she was gonna get me
do you
please don't let go oh god all right um I know she has
Scour help me long live the king I'm fine oh hold on well where is this going
You're scouting okay, that's not that bad. I'm gonna see how far I can get
What the frick look the loop oh and the carrots right there. Oh, I'm dead all right now we know
Do not you're good. You're fine. I knew I trusted you you think I know you would catch up. Oh
Sorry making us go back. See I could have done that too
Okay, it's working. I thought we were gonna go backwards again nice all right
Who needs horsepower any of bunny power
Um acrobatics acrobatics all right grab my feet
Perfect
Sabotage again the game it glitches and then sometimes I don't see when I kick mercy. Oh
Oh, it's fine
My cat is watching us play and great Ernest
Nice nice holding on nevermind
Oh
Go forth mercy actually yeah, see how far you can get
What the fuck is happening
It's Raina Raina is watching here my body being sliced up in the distance
She's she's glitching so hard for me she's just floating through the air
Take the loop do you loo oh my god look at her knees
Grip in the oh
Nice okay that we can go backwards for the carrot and then then the portals probably right there
Okay, cool. Yeah, we got it. All right. We mapped out. We've mapped out the area. We got this
Oh
I'm so scared we're gonna flip this over nice. Oh
I
Shall wait oh
My god, you are cheating death nice
All right, we should probably flip yeah perfect and oh I need to hold on I need to hold on we need to hold on
We need to hold on
I made it oh we missed the carrot though
How many do we need how many oh we need one more okay, okay?
We should go back we should do this one again. We have 24. What the hell it shows me 23. Oh
man
All right, let's do that one again and grab the carrot that one seems kind of easy to get
Yeah
Kind of we got this let's flip over that jump over that oh shit
We're gonna fall off
Oh, no my cat right up right up
First seat can you come grab me? Yeah, never mind never mind my fingers
Raina just sabotaged me
I'm so upset
I
Often does rain a very often or boomie usually her and boomie up
I'm just gonna do some pull-ups
Glad you could join me. Oh
Go back. Yes pro strats
Nice
Yoga pose and effect
All right, let me flip off
I
Wonder if we can actually take that can we take it with us? Let me see
I'm not strong enough
I don't think I can why did it let me do that
Why was I so strong that I could just
Now I want to keep trying to take it. I can't
All right
All right, hold it on I'm not oh no, I got it
I
Need to rub my cheeks. Oh my god my mouth
Oh my mouth cheeks people will calm down
Oh
Oh my god, okay
It's fine. It's fine
We're good
All right, you got my feet
All right, you got your feet
I can't craft a thing. Okay. I got your feet now
Well, we can just hang out like this
Okay, can we flip it again? Let's see if we can
And
Okay, damn it. Let's do it that time
It's okay
Marcy
I got it
All right, and we can just flip together to this one
And you can hold on
And I'll just jockey style hold on as well
Oh god
Okay, are you serious?
That's fine. Are you serious?
Oh, it's not fine
Okay, I guess we got to be balanced to like
Like not in the middle, but I think like we both have to be holding on
I can't be holding on to you or you can't be holding on to me
I feel so cheated me too
It's fine. It's okay. It'll come back. It'll come back. Don't worry. It'll bounce back to us. No, it won't actually ever got
This is the one that does that. Um, hold on to me. Maybe it works
No, I forgot it goes down so it won't come back up. Yeah, that was another one that did that
Taking a sip of my wawa
Nice
You
Take it with us take it with us
Take it with us
All right, that's not working. Uh, fuck wait
Uh
Oh, sorry, please do not kick me. I'm trying to flip it back over
What I wasn't even near you on my screen
What the hell that was weird
My chat can tell you I was not even near you
Wait, I'm not dead. Okay now I am
Okay, all right
The physics are not fizzicking
No, I'm holding on. I'm holding on. Yes. Okay. We got it. Yes
Oh
It's moving backwards
I'll push off I'll push off. Yeah momentum
All right, let me just flip. Yeah, yeah, perfect
All right, you're good
Nice amazing
Okay, wait, hold on to me. Okay. All right, we're both on
Nice, okay, perfect
Wait
I got it. We made the loop get ready. Let go
Yes, okay, you got it. I got the carrot. I'm gonna grab it. I'm grabbing it
Slowly but surely
Oh, hello raiders who raided. Sorry. I totally didn't
Oh, welcome Kendra. Thank you for the raid. Welcome raiders. Are you playing?
Yeah
Oh, wait, is this the next level? This is the next level. Okay
I'll wait for you
Oh
I'm so happy you can grip ice. Oh my god
Uh, good luck to the both of us trying to jump up here. How is that gonna work? Oh wait?
I know. Um, I'm gonna hold here and then you can push off me. Oh, there we go. Yeah
Just grab onto the ice
It's not working
Oh
Oh, I managed to finally get up
I died though. Yeah, I saw
All right, let me see what we're at
All right, there's a little blood bounce too. Uh, can I oh my god
I wanted to go see what was ahead
Totally hundred percent this game. I don't know if we could
Ah, wait, what's wrong? Oh, thank you. Thank you. What's happening?
Thank you kind one
Okay
Oh, I just slowly slide off screen. Okay, this is we're gonna need to highlights of this stream
All right
All right, this is so hard not to die on from these spikes
um
On my butt wait, you died now I did I wasn't dead and now I am take me with you
Oh
Nice oh god
Oh, okay, I think I want to go the other way for this
Oh, are you kidding me bro, bro. Hold on. Let me see. Let me scout it. Yes. Let's go
Nice, okay, so that means we can knock that down
Cool
Oh god, how are we supposed to okay, uh, you'll probably have to go backwards. Yeah, and then you have to really kick off
Nice, okay, and the thing is probably right there. Yeah, it's probably right there. Okay. Okay, go
Okay, I somehow assist you melon. Yeah, thank you
No, thank you again
Slowing my speed down
I'm so scared mercy mercy. I don't want to die
I'm stuck
Oh my
I think this might be the level for me that I won't be able to pass
Don't forget to hit that like and subscribe button kids
Don't forget to hit the like and subscribe. It really helps out the channel
And don't forget I make new videos every week
And by g fuel with our codes mercy and she be to get 10% off
I mean
Oh
I'm ending stream right now
Gamer stops
We hate that g fuel shit
Okay
Use code she be at gamer stops and mercy
We hate the other competitors. We don't even know them. I don't even know them. Who is who are they? Who is she?
Oh
Hey guys, I'm feeling really sluggish and tired today
Anyone know a good way to increase my energy without drinking those insanely sugary energy drinks
Oh my gosh, do I have the product for you harlot? I highly recommend gamer stops
They have the most amazing flavors and such unique names and cool shaker cups
Nothing like anything else on the market
Use code she be and mercy for 10% off and you
Can be amazing today
And be a real gamer
What's up
I'm gonna go kill myself
In this game, of course
It's so funny because mercy said the wrong thing earlier and I corrected her and now she's doing it to me
This is before stream started though
Oh, I mixed them up because they
It's okay. We both it's it's it's okay. It's okay. Don't worry about it
Oh, oh, oh, okay. Oh, we made it with the power of gamer sups. We made it
We love gamer sups
Stan gamer sups everyone. Strani's gonna fucking beat my ass after this stream. I'm so scared
I think I'm also dead
Well, goodbye
Let me die
I can't wait to edit the bond
I'll edit the bond too. Don't worry. Is that 215?
Oh
We are never okay. Listen. I'm I'm new to this sort of
I'm so sorry. It's okay
Everybody's cracking up right now
We
Uh made it alive
Wait, did you die?
Ah
No, don't summon the clippers
You so died give me a second. I didn't die. I don't know what you're talking about
I think I just heard my body hit the spring
Strani, I'm sorry, please don't hurt me
I love you mommy
Thank you
I made my gamer sups thing so big
Oh, we made it. Okay. Um
Jump over. I can't move. What do you mean? I can't move. Okay, I fixed it. It's because I clicked off the screen
Okay
Oh, hello
Go that way. He's stealing this
Look at us. Nope. Come back
I'm trying to come back
Oh, no, no, no
Wait, what is happening let go
Oh
She's so strong what the fuck just happened
Can I lift this guy over we we switched places
That was so weird
Okay, let me just I need to like flip
Oh my god, you see those I'm fucking call me messy. I'm a footballer
Oh
All right, yes stuck there cool in an order
To win I'm waiting for you to go well, I'm waiting to go back because oh, okay, I need to kick off of this fucking ball
Nice, okay, my turn
Nope, I'm going too fast
Go back to the ball and kick off of it
Falco kick
I'm killing myself
I hate this gate
I'm so
I can't do this right now
I didn't fucking die never mind I died
Oh
My god, I'm sending an apology right
Fix it
I can't fix it because I can't see it. Wait
There it is. Let me grab it. No, that's the game
I can't
I'm just trying to
It's still too big it's still fucking huge
I'll put it in the corner
Okay
Okay, I think once we beat this one I gotta get off because I'm losing my mind
I have never laughed this hard in my life. I'm getting a minecrate
Why I can't oh, okay, thank you
What am I doing?
Oh
Actually that was helpful
Did you just fucking reappear what do you mean?
Oh
Look at me. Look at this. Oh, oh skill
Oh my god, imagine if we were drunk doing this. This is a sober guys. This is a sober imagine us on gamer subs
Energized with amazing wholesome energy white with their amazing flavors and that you could get
I can't get up help I'm falling and I can't get oh, I'm good
Oh shit
I
Can't even see I'm crying. I can't even see through my tears. I can't even talk
No, don't mix gamer subs with alcohol please says don't do that
Oh
Someday I'll get there
Don't just just you wait
Just you wait when I get my cotton bud over there
You're gonna rue the day
Spike just wait spike just grab the ice
I
Grab there you go
Now don't move too much
There you go. Oh my god, okay. Oh god. I just make it over this jump
I'm watching and then
Take over that where the fuck is the carrot? I have no idea where the carrot is
Oh god, just wait for you to go back. There you go
Oh
Okay, I'm done. I can't I can't okay. Would you like to go to just chatting straight? Yeah
Would you like to talk alone with your chat?
I can't talk at all
I'm crying
I don't want to sit
Oh my god
I'm so sorry
I'm laughing. I might like sad crying. I'm laughing crying. I swear
Oh
It's okay. You can take your time. It's okay. We can talk later. I love you mercy
I love you too. I'll see you
Thank you for playing with me. That was the most fun I've had in a long time
Thank you
Everybody say bye to kohe
Oh
Okay, okay, all right breathe breathe
I say that not breathing myself
Did you hear that no
Oh
I just heard a what what what what I did not hear that
Who the fuck there's nobody else in the chat with us. What just happened?
What the hell
I'm losing it. Am I losing it? Okay. I'm not I'm not going crazy
Oh my god, it's okay
Here I'll move to the just chatting. I don't think you appear in just chatting for me. So
I love you. I love you mercy
I want to go here. Let's let's I'll get out of the the call
Bye
Talk to you later
She's still here in spirit with her model
Hello make funny faces
Oh, no, she disappeared before I could make funny faces
Oh, let me make myself bigger
Uh, I hope you guys had fun
Oh
I can't stop laughing one from embarrassment
You know what?
I guess the game is just funny. Oh my god
Hold on I just
Thanks for becoming members
Okay, straw knee didn't fucking end my life. I'm good. I'm still in vial there guys
I can't even get me out of this fucking game, bro
Oh, I lost it
Okay, well, I'm gonna read someone
Uh, let me look for someone to read
You wipe the tears from my eyes. I don't know why the chat's gone. Not that it matters. It's
I want to let me redirect
Oh, I need to go to bed
Um
Go go say hi
Say hi to Tumomi Toraya
From VNU
She's playing free country
Tell her that I died from laughter from playing my own game with mercy
I'm gonna get off now
I need to go lay down
My head hurts so bad from laughing so hard
You can just say super bunny raid. Okay. Bye guys
Thanks for putting up with me
That's a big thanks straw knee for putting up with me. Yes, my hair is cut off. I don't care
I'm leaving. I need to go to bed. Goodbye
Use code she be
For 10% off